I saw this morning you were frantically
attempting to download the latest piece
of downloadable content yeah we're a
division yeah I'm entitled to
underground that is correct it is the
first piece of page DLC I want to say
that is also first of free I believe
that is also correct costs 1499 I also
believe that is correct Oh on what is
the cut that's basically all I know that
that's all you got so what is that why I
even know basically it's like a bigger
update than the update statement giving
I guess as in this one you do get
another incursion but you also get this
whole new area called the underground
right ELC would say a lot of the enemies
and people you've been dealing with have
all fled but they're underground while
I'm trying to rise up again sort of
there in the New York subway system that
I'm guessing yeah okay um so basically
you do miss holdout just using Milton's
lasers map to get around so basically
turn the trains on [ __ ] problems on
use a train them dudes and yeah okay
below mission ah you gotta get to the
mission with the trains I have deep
grunt rhyme is it can you dig it nice
barking thanks that's why we keep you
here Mike there you go Eric yes so uh
yeah you do a mission and it's like oh
you got to go to this other area in your
HQ that's like lower down below and
there's like a underground basically an
underground HQ that you're going to and
basically I would say the bulk of the
content is kind of this new operations
type of content which is randomly
generated dungeons or like areas that
you're going to go in and fight you know
Rikers cleaners it rioters it's all the
same people we've had upstairs just
saved things yeah gone down for those
that they fled down there so you're kind
of going down there to kind of take care
of them because you don't want them to
kind of you know cumulate forces and
whatnot no it's it's interesting only
because I guess it's you haven't
necessarily played this style I guess
because it's randomly generated and
you're not you don't know what you're
going to fight those new traps or just
kind of like these jammer things that if
you don't take them out they kind of
they make your skills ineffective until
you take it out so that stuff you have
to deal with and
some of the quarters are a little
tighter and there's like traps you can
kind of hear them but you're like oh
where is it yeah what are the areas
liked in there because there were subway
stations in the division proper so like
do they look like that are they bigger
do they look different at all the
environment I would say but not
necessarily I mean I haven't played too
much unfortunately cuz i got that delta
error which i think they fixed now right
but it was like stopping me from getting
in for like an hour but it's kind of the
same just different kind of tile sets
and i think they're different each time
you do an operation and then on top of
that not necessarily just talking about
environment but as you level up your
base of operations you get the ability
to change some of these missions and so
there's things like fog war as a like a
negative perk kind of thing or like mad
skills and you basically you pay for
these little attributes to make the
missions harder right and by doing so
you get better okay eventually and i was
the loot so far as are we in a situation
there were they look so good that it's
made all your currently redundant er I
mean it's it depends on where you came
from before this expansion I would say
that you know the hardcore people will
probably have their sets like really
good fine-tuned min max gear so take
them a little bit more time to get that
stuff like the newer stuff because there
are new set items there's new armor set
items and then there's also new weapons
so that's kind of like what you're
hunting for right but as a casual player
who like even for me I stopped playing
for a while yeah I'm still like 95 or
something right I'm like well so there's
I like a level cap past 30 kind of like
in destiny like a light level getting
where I think I was like 195 which isn't
super high I think you could got to like
220 in the last big update but it's
easier to get to that I think I already
got to like 205 in just playing right
our okay so it's kind of got that wow
effect where if you haven't been playing
you know you can jump back into some of
these missions these cuz there's varying
degrees there's a card mode there's
challenging mode and they've even added
a heroic mode then the missions
themselves is it more of the same like
just taking it dudes is their bosses at
the end is it all around to be generated
or is there like specific like and raid
bosses that you have um I mean like
they're pretty much like missions that
least the dungeons are you kind of going
through different phases of a map and
then at the annual generally fight a
named boss and like a bunch of you know
thugs and whatnot there's like you know
protect the generator kind of stuff
there's also you know like plant
explosive kind of stuff so it's still
kind of objective wise it's still kind
of the same so I haven't played the new
incursion though which you know again
it's I'm sure there's some added element
that may be slightly different from
everything else but there isn't
something super creatively different
right yes it's like is it what it sounds
to me like this could have been
something that they would have put out
it as a free update I mean 15 bucks
isn't the most expensive thing in the
world but for people who bought like the
gold edition does this this is enough
for you um this is an interesting one
because it's like I feel like if you
were playing the division already this
is great right but then also the reason
why this expansion maybe doesn't look as
big at glance is because they did give
those to kind of big updates with the
incursion and like little minor like
quality of life tweaks and they're kind
of reiterating as they go so then it
kind of like they gave all that stuff
away for free but yeah exactly so then
it kind of makes this one feel a little
bit weird I mean you are getting
something like kind of new and different
in a way just because they're you know
you have the randomly generated dungeons
you can add all these different things
so it does change the way you play
because like something like mad skills
or something if you use one of your
skills it basically takes both puts them
both on cooldown so you have to be
mindful of that your team has to be
mindful of that so there are these
elements but it's also granular kind of
stuff I guess so I'm doing in a way
that's what division fans want I guess
Mike have you played since launch much
like five hours okay from what you're
explaining to me maybe it's because it's
you explaining it and it just sounds
like chalice dungeons from blood-borne
it's either that or it's kind of almost
in a way so the thing about the division
is it takes a lot of like Diablo type of
elements without sure to understand a
lot so it's kind of like doing riffs
Yeah right like I'm kind of doing like
Nephilim riffs and like even like you
get cash you get like a little like
satchel value type thing sure you finish
the operations and you opening your like
oh sweet i got a piece of loot so like
in terms of your like the rewards and
stuff like that that's why for me as
it's someone that hasn't played yet you
do get more stuff register but those do
seem ideal for people that have been
playing and that's cool I mean it's
going to help people to have been
playing much like if I jumped into it I
don't know
probably dialogue but for like rifts and
Diablo the reason I love those because I
was so tired of trekking through the
story time and time again so I mean that
felt worth it but I haven't played a
division much more than like I think
five hours I played it I was actually
having fun with it the early stages but
I never got to the actual like mid
maxing level like you did very soon when
after launch I keep telling myself I'm
going to go back to it just just to play
it because I don't feel like I gave it
the chance it might deserve but then I
keep hearing like things about these
updates that don't really entice me to
do so yeah also it's hard to like just
right now in terms of like where we are
at because there's games like overwatch
you know and all these other games that
I'm even today tweeted I was like what
do I play today there's iron an iron
banner event in destiny which hasn't
been around for a little bit and then
there's obviously the division expansion
and then i still play overwatch at night
so it's like how do i find time to do
spite do my degree I beat you know do
great and I'm at lunchtime like finally
do you got that damn boss I got the last
night and I couldn't beat in the
lunchtime today that's pretty good yeah
yeah but they go to division underground
oh now 1499 also available in the gold
edition if you bought that in fact
actually steam has twenty-five percent
off both of those right now so if you
want to pick up the division if you
haven't already it's sixty dollars
usually its center for 4499 the gold
edition down to 74 99 it's until the
fourth of July
you